>> Will Sentance: Bắt đầu đi, Jason, dòng một,
chúng ta đang lưu những gì trong bộ nhớ chung [SOUND] của mình?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Chúng tôi đang ràng buộc người tạo nhãn người dùng, với chức năng,
đến thời gian chức năng >> Will Sentance: Fantastic.
Đây rồi.
Có một định nghĩa hàm.
Dòng tiếp theo, qua Ethan, hết cỡ, đánh cái gì, ở phía bên tay trái,
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Định nghĩa một const người dùng.
>> Will Sentance: Nhân tiện, tôi muốn nói với mọi người rằng,
chỉ cần biết bạn khác thường như thế nào, ngay cả trong môi trường kỹ thuật chuyên nghiệp
mà bây giờ bạn chỉ cần bắt đầu, vâng, thật tuyệt, chuỗi JavaScript sẽ biến mất ở đó.
Như vậy không phải là tiêu chuẩn, thậm chí có sự phát triển lại đầy đủ, trực quan,
những gì bạn đã làm ở đó, Ethan, xuất sắc.
Hiện nay.
Chúa ơi, tôi vừa ngủ kinh khủng.
Chà!
Tôi đang băt đâu mệt đây.
Tại sao tôi lại làm vậy?
Xin lỗi, mọi người.
Bạn có biết điều gì sẽ xảy ra với người dùng không?
Không ý kiến.
Thật tốt khi tôi đã làm điều đó, vì nó giống như, chúng tôi không biết.
Bởi vì chúng ta phải đi và làm gì, Ethan?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Người tạo cuộc gọi.
>> Di chúc: Đúng, và trong khi chờ đợi,
người dùng chắc chắn không phải là một đối tượng, và nó không biết nó sẽ như thế nào,
thực tế nó là gì?
>> Loa 2: Chưa được khởi tạo.
>> Will Sentance: Chưa được khởi tạo, chính xác.
Cảm ơn Peter, bạn cũng sẽ nói điều tương tự, rằng Ethan, vì vậy
chúng ta hãy gọi người tạo người dùng.
Chúng ta sẽ vào chung kết ngay đây, mọi người.
Chà, trận chung kết, trận chung kết, vòng cuối cùng, đường thẳng cuối cùng của trận chung kết.
Được rồi, tôi không biết.
Tôi định tiếp tục, được rồi, chúng ta đang đánh mất nó.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi bắt đầu, chúng tôi đang gọi Người tạo người dùng,
thương hiệu mới- >> Diễn giả 2: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh thực hiện, tại chỗ, chính xác.
Vào đó, chúng tôi đi.
Rất mãnh liệt các bạn ạ.
Được rồi, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Và trong Bộ nhớ cục bộ, hãy có
hãy có bạn của chúng tôi, Dan.
Dan, hãy xử lý điều đầu tiên, chúng tôi luôn xử lý khi chúng tôi thực thi một hàm
gọi một hàm, và đó là để xử lý?
>> Diễn giả 2: Tranh luận.
>> Will Sentance: Lập luận của chúng tôi, và tất cả đều là con người, điều đầu tiên là ý chí, và
tham số của nó được gán là?
>> Người nói 2: Tên. >> Di chúc: Tên, vâng,
hãy thực sự chính xác, đó là bởi vì nó hơi bị đóng băng, mọi người.
Tôi đã đưa cái này cho bạn tuần trước, bạn biết đó là kỹ sư nhỏ, họ đã
bị ném ra một chút bởi những gì chúng ta đang xem, vì tôi có thể thấy hai cái tên, trong dòng đó bên dưới.
Chúng ta sẽ biết lý do tại sao, sau một giây.
Được rồi, tên, xuất sắc.
Và sau đó tham số tiếp theo là?
>> Người nói 2: Điểm, giá trị của ba.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng.
Đừng ai nghĩ rằng đây là tài sản.
Đây chỉ là các biến dữ liệu, bạn biết đấy, nhãn, giống như bất kỳ biến nào khác.
Chúng chỉ là những cái mà chúng ta phải để lại một chỗ dành sẵn, ngay từ đầu và
sau đó điền trước khi chúng tôi chạy chức năng, bạn nhé.
Bây giờ, chúng ta nhập phần thân của hàm.
Braden, chúng ta phải làm gì trong hàng một?
>> Loa 2: Khai báo người dùng mới không đổi, là đối tượng mới.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, cảm ơn bạn, Braden.
Được rồi, giao cho bạn, Kayla.
Cố lên [LAUGH], tôi thực sự luôn đấu tranh với điều đó.
Cho bạn, Kayla.
>> Người thuyết trình 3: Chúng tôi đang đặt tên thuộc tính cho người dùng mới
object- >> Will Sentance: Tôi thích điều đó.
>> Loa 3: Đến giá trị của tên đối số.
>> Will Sentance: Thật xuất sắc, đúng chỗ.
Bây giờ, điều đó thực sự quan trọng ở đó, vì nó có một chút
kỳ lạ mà chúng tôi đang nói, hãy tìm kiếm người dùng mới và ngụ ý rằng ở đó
là một thuộc tính tên trên nó, hoặc nếu không có tạo nó bây giờ trong đối tượng.
Đây không phải là một biến, phải không?
Đây không phải là nhãn, đây không phải là số nhận dạng.
Đây là một thuộc tính trên đối tượng, người dùng mới.
Đúng như Kayla đã nói, hãy tạo ra nó và gán cho nó bất cứ thứ gì,
vì vậy vào bên phải của dấu bằng, bất cứ điều gì ở bên phải ở đó,
đi tìm cái đó trong bộ nhớ.
Nó sẽ thêm chuỗi sẽ và chúng tôi lưu trữ trong tên đúng.
Đúng như Kayla nói.
Hãy làm lại lần nữa, Kayla, nếu bạn phiền, dòng tiếp theo nói phải làm gì?
>> Người thuyết trình 3: Chúng tôi đặt điểm thuộc tính trên đối tượng người dùng mới thành giá trị của điểm,
là 2.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng, chính xác là lập luận của chúng tôi.
Điểm tham số là giá trị đối số, 3, được lưu trữ trong đó.
Dan, đoạn cuối ở đây, chúng ta đang làm gì?
>> Người nói 2: Chúng tôi đang tạo ra một bước tăng
function- >> Will Sentance: Đúng.
>> Người nói 2: Về người dùng mới- >> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy.
>> Người nói 2: Và nói điều đó- >> Câu Di chúc: Đây rồi,
lưu tất cả mã của nó, lưu tất cả mã của nó, hãy nghĩ về việc lưu tất cả mã của nó.
Nhưng tôi muốn điều đó, bởi vì tôi muốn có thể làm cho người dùng mới, tốt, trong vòng một giây.
Đây rồi, tôi có một vật đẹp.
Nó có mọi thứ tôi cần.
Nhưng, Jeff, nó bị mắc kẹt bên trong bối cảnh thực thi của người tạo người dùng.
Tôi cần làm gì để đưa nó trở thành người dùng?
Tôi trả lại nó, chính xác, trả lại nó.
Và biết rằng toàn bộ phần này ở đây thực sự đánh giá,
biến cái này trả lại đối tượng đó, và lưu trữ cái bất thường đó.
Vậy là xong, đây rồi,
người dùng một đối tượng và nhìn vào đối tượng đó, mọi người,
nó giống hệt như thiết lập trước đây của chúng tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Đây rồi, và bây giờ chúng ta có chức năng tuyệt vời ở đó.
Tôi muốn nói một điều nhỏ, rằng tôi không, hãy chết.
Chúng tôi sẽ đến thứ hai.
Hãy quay lại toàn cầu như hiện tại và nhấn dòng tiếp theo, khai báo người dùng 2.
Tôi sẽ làm điều này ở đây, mặc dù nó có vẻ lặp đi lặp lại, vì tôi muốn bạn
phát hiện thứ gì đó có thể hơi thừa hoặc rất thừa, hoặc.
Về cơ bản, và từ cơ bản,
và, đừng bận tâm, về cơ bản là thừa.
Chúng tôi sẽ chạy trình tạo người dùng một lần nữa, chúng tôi sẽ tạo
bối cảnh thực thi mới, Tommy Paulson, Tim và năm người này.
Bạn tôi là bạn của tôi từ thời đi học.
Những người bạn rất tốt.
Tôi không biết tại sao, lẽ ra tôi nên đổi những cái tên này từ lâu.
Tôi nghĩ rằng tôi nghĩ trong phiên bản OP của tất cả, nhưng
Tôi đã đổi tên, tôi không biết tại sao từ lâu, bốn năm trước,
Tôi đặt nó là Tim, bạn của tôi, người bạn duy nhất của tôi từ thời đại học.
Trên thực tế, tôi muốn có nó trong hồ sơ, tôi có nhiều, không,
không, [LAUGH] kể cả anh ấy, tôi cũng không chắc anh ấy coi tôi là bạn.
Được rồi, dù sao thì, tôi nghĩ anh ấy coi tôi là đồng nghiệp.
Được rồi, vì vậy trong bối cảnh thực thi này, chúng ta đi >> Will Sentance: Tôi sẽ
giữ nó nhỏ, bây giờ.
Và trong bộ nhớ cục bộ, >> Will Sentance: Chúng ta sẽ có,
Tôi không biết tại sao tôi lại làm cho nó nhỏ như vậy, nhưng chúng ta bắt đầu.
Tên, Tim, điểm số, năm.
Sau đó, chúng tôi tạo một đối tượng, người dùng mới.
Tệ thật, không hiểu sao lại làm nhỏ thế này.
Một đối tượng, người dùng mới với thuộc tính tên,
lưu giá trị đó vào giá trị của tham số tên, có đối số là hai.
Điểm, năm, tại sao tôi làm cho nó quá nhỏ?
Tôi không biết.
Và, gia tăng, lưu một thương hiệu
chức năng mới, tất cả mã của nó.
Vì vậy, tôi biết rằng trên đối tượng đó, khi nó được trả về cho người dùng hai,
nó sẽ đẹp,
nó sẽ có một phương pháp gia tăng đẹp mắt trên đó.
Đây rồi, tên, Tim, điểm số,
năm, và số tăng, là một hàm,
và bây giờ chúng tôi thực hiện tất cả các kiểm tra quan trọng của chúng tôi.
Chúng ta có thể làm, người dùng 2, dấu chấm hoặc bất kỳ người nào trong số họ, nhưng
đó là user2.increment.
Todd, cho bạn, tra cứu thời gian, người dùng 2, nó ở đâu?
>> Người nói 2: Trong bộ nhớ toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu, chúng tôi có nó.
>> Người nói 2: Có. >> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy.
Tăng lên, nó là một thuộc tính, nó là một phương thức trên người dùng 2?
>> Người nói 2: Có. >> Will Sentance: Vâng, đúng vậy, chúng tôi lấy nó.
Tôi sẽ không thực hiện nó ngay bây giờ.
Nhưng chỉ cần nghĩ về những gì mã gia tăng nói.
Nó nói, điểm số chấm của người dùng mới ++, nhưng tôi khá chắc chắn rằng không có người dùng mới nào ở đây.
Và chúng tôi đã đánh mất điều đó.
Trừ khi phần tăng hàm được lưu trữ ở đây có ba lô [CROSSTALK],
đó là một liên kết đến tên, tên cũ của cùng một chức năng, nghĩa là nếu tôi chạy,
như một phần thưởng rất nhỏ, và mọi người, đừng lo lắng về điều này, nếu bạn tiếp tục,
khi tôi chạy tăng dần bạn, bởi vì chúng tôi sẽ không sử dụng kiểu này.
Chúng tôi sẽ không bao giờ sử dụng phong cách này, vì vậy chúng tôi không cần phải chăm chăm vào nó.
Nhưng chỉ cần lưu ý cách đóng ở mọi nơi, đối tượng được trả về,
hàm tăng bên trong nó cho biết newUser.score ++.
Người mới ở đâu?
Bối cảnh thực thi này, hãy nói rõ, đã bị xóa.
Cả hai đều đã bị xóa, nhưng, vì đối tượng, khi nó trở lại đã
một chức năng trên nó, chức năng đó đã được liên kết với tất cả bộ nhớ xung quanh
bao gồm cả người dùng mới, vốn là nhãn cho cùng một đối tượng.
Ý tôi là chúng tôi vẫn nhận được nhãn người dùng mới bên trong gia số và
nó sẽ tham chiếu đến user2.
Ba lô ở khắp mọi nơi.
Tôi chỉ muốn thưởng một ít tiền đó,
bởi vì chúng tôi đã thấy ba lô trong phiên này, nhưng đừng lo lắng về nó.
Bởi vì chúng tôi sẽ không bao giờ sử dụng cách tiếp cận này.
Nhưng cách tiếp cận này về cơ bản đã hiệu quả, dễ lý giải?
Bạn đặt cược đó là.
Tôi có chức năng của mình ngay tại đó, ở phía bên phải của dấu chấm, tôi có thể
hãy điền trước Google Tìm kiếm, người dùng hai dấu chấm, nó sẽ điền.
Nếu tôi có các chức năng khác được lưu trữ ở đó, tất cả chúng sẽ ở đó,
Tôi có thể bắt đầu viết, và chúng sẽ xuất hiện theo đúng nghĩa đen.
Đó là thiết kế của codex bạn chọn, nhưng nó nói lên thực tế
rằng các chức năng đó hoàn toàn, theo nghĩa đen trên đối tượng.
Có sẵn.
Xinh đẹp tuyệt trần.
Chúng ta xong chưa?
Đã được thực hiện.
Dễ dàng giải thích, không cần tìm kiếm với các chức năng,
không nghĩ rằng chức năng này thực sự áp dụng cho người dùng bài kiểm tra của tôi.
Câu hỏi đố 17 của tôi, bởi vì nó nằm trên đối tượng này, và
tuy nhiên, cách tiếp cận này hoàn toàn không sử dụng được, bởi vì tôi đã nói
có hai mục tiêu khác, và mô hình của tôi, những gì tôi nói, chúng là?
Dễ dàng thêm các tính năng vào chức năng mới, mới, và tuy nhiên,
chính thức trước khi mọi người cho tôi biết điều gì, với phong cách này,
về cơ bản là sai, rằng tôi không bao giờ có thể sử dụng cái này, Dan, hãy tiếp tục.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Chúng tôi đang lưu trữ cùng một chức năng hai lần.
>> Will Sentance: Anh ấy đúng chỗ.
Không có gì tránh khỏi nó, rằng dữ liệu này chúng tôi không thể.
Chúng tôi không thể, bạn biết đấy, không lưu trữ T và năm, Will và ba, đó là những dữ liệu khác nhau.
Vì vậy, tôi lại có một câu chuyện, nó khác, nhưng mã của hàm này, và
mã của chức năng này, giống hệt nhau, và
nếu tôi có 500 người dùng cần có chức năng tăng dần, vì vậy
rằng chúng tôi có thể làm cho chúng tôi một 703.increment, tôi nói năm người trong số chúng tôi và sử dụng nó 495.increment.
Tôi phải có một bản sao của nó, phải không?
Và nếu cả hai cách, tôi chỉ có một chức năng, tôi có 100, 200, ba, bốn,
năm, nghĩa là hàng trăm.
Tất cả họ sẽ được gọi, tôi sẽ có bản sao của từng người trong số họ,
mỗi người trong số họ có thể 10 dòng mã.
Tôi có 1000 người dùng, tức là 10.000.
Và sau đó mỗi chức năng là 100.
Tôi đang lãng phí 10 phần nghìn dòng mã ở đây.
Vì vậy, không gian trong bộ nhớ cũng sẽ thêm.
Ngoài ra, một điều khác khiến người ta đau đầu về điều này, có lẽ, hoặc
Có vấn đề về điều này, vâng, Peter.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Nếu bạn muốn thêm một tính năng vào điều này,
bạn phải thêm nó vào từng người dùng.
>> Will Sentance: Hoàn hảo, chính xác như tôi nói.
Vâng, tại chỗ, chúng tôi sẽ phải thêm chức năng theo cách thủ công nếu chúng tôi muốn thêm
một tính năng, đó là chức năng mới.
Thêm thủ công nó vào mọi đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Nhưng tôi sẽ nói điều này, siêu trực quan.
Không có gì bí ẩn, tất nhiên tôi có thể sử dụng hàm tăng dần user2,
nó ở ngay đó trên đối tượng.
Tạo các đối tượng bằng cách sử dụng một hàm vấn đề, mỗi khi chúng tôi tạo một người dùng mới,
chúng tôi tạo không gian trong bộ nhớ của máy tính đó cho các chức năng dữ liệu của chúng tôi.
Nhưng chức năng đó chỉ là bản sao của cùng một mã.
Có cách nào tốt hơn?
Chúng ta sẽ thấy.